let's let's okay let's let's jump to the
last segment before we go to super chats
because this is huge
ian you're correct good sir i thought so
joe rogan
has removed 1.85
billion views from his youtube channel
whoa
so uh so for those that are listening
ian he comes to he comes to me earlier
and he says like yo all of joe rogan's
videos are gone
and i said surely you just good sir ian
joe said that he's gonna keep all of his
episodes on his channel
archived forever and they're they're
gone
most of them most of them so we looked
into it and there's i don't know how
many
you know 50 plus 1.854 billion so
look we have social blade right here
check this out in in on december
2nd 1.877 billion views were subtracted
from his channel
and then on december 3rd 53 million so
right just the day after he went
exclusive to spotify
the reason why this matters to a lot of
people and i'm not one for
you know getting into like i don't know
celebrity gossip or anything
this is this is a bit different and uh i
do know joe personally
i haven't asked him about this but joe
is one of the most important political
figures whether he wants to be or not
there's a reason why the left constantly
wants to cancel him why they they demand
spotify censor him
and now to see that all of these
episodes are gone
and are exclusive to spotify so long as
they still exist i guess i'm happy but
remember
i don't wha did they ever did joe
restore all the episodes that went
missing
i don't know so so here's the here's the
original story right
joe goes to spotify transfers over the
podcasts and then a bunch of episodes
didn't transfer over
and people noticed that these episodes
were very interestingly from certain
people
alex jones gavin mcginnis i think um
people like that peterson yeah yeah
but but my understanding was that it was
a it was an error of some sort but don't
worry
every episode will be available forever
on youtube we see that that's not the
case anymore check it out i'll
pull it to youtube when you go to his
actual channel
so i've sorted by oldest you can see the
oldest he's got these videos from back
in the day seven years ago
but it's just i i don't understand
you know why these specific videos i
guess these are all the biggest
podcasts ever yeah like 4.4 million
views and more and higher
yeah i mean this is a shame i mean the
conversations the comments the views
uh a lot of people utilized those you
know in their lives and they were very
important for so many people and now to
see them gone it's
it's a little disappointing to me i
guess they're on spotify my
is my guess i tried to i want to point
people to david sinclair joe rogan
uh the second one where sinclair is like
a life extension guy from harvard he's
awesome david sinclair so i did this
show on saturday with um
seth from venice beach dog club shout
out seth and talked about david sinclair
and then i went to rogan's channel right
after that and that's when i found out
it was gone there's a lot of people also
saying that this is because
joe rogan is allegedly having a hard
time translating his youtube audience
into spotify
there's a couple articles wow talking
about that there's one
here by sportskita.com that says
it's titled joe rogan fans are refusing
to follow him to spotify
and it's bad so you know they outline
how a lot of people are just aren't
translating so actually i have i have a
a couple articles i've got from uh
dexertoe.com joe rogan fans outraged her
podcast moves exclusively to spotify
i thought that was kind of silly though
because we knew he was going to do it
but
now i see exactly why people are
probably really angry getting all the
episodes
pulled from the biggest podcast in the
world it was just an incredible trove of
information
it's maybe sad sad loss and i imagine
he's just private he's just probably
private at all
maybe uh they're they're gone from this
channel the views have been removed
but that makes sense if people so so
check this out we have this story from
the new york post this is from
aurora why the left is lashing out at jo
i'm sorry this is the wrong one i i need
to go to the fans one right
why the fans are upset they say as of
december 2nd
full episode of the podcast are
exclusively available on spotify and
highlight clips
will appear on on youtube in the
comments section of the youtube clip
fans release release their frustration
towards the exclusive move
it's been a hell of a ride guys see ya
one viewer said one fan said bye to the
podcast in their comment
this feels like a breakup and i feel
cheated for a richer guy
by jre another disappointed viewer
revealed that while they tried listening
to the show on spotify they couldn't
handle the 10 straight minutes of ads
that's kind of silly because if you've
ever listened to the actual podcast on
itunes or whatever
he has ads running on it so most people
probably don't care they're going to say
the move over to spotify certainly
brought about some dissatisfaction
but that's the interesting point maybe
because
that's you mentioned right because he
couldn't generate he could get enough
people to translate over
yes he takes the videos off of youtube
he wasn't going to do that originally
but maybe spotify said yo we're not
getting big viewership on spotify
well spotify again invested a lot into
joe rogan
and there was a lot of internal battles
and fights that they had to clear up
internally just to just to get this joe
rogan train running
and yeah this the employees kept
revolting yes which was
uh pretty ridiculous to think an
individual has
the power to you know control what you
could listen to or not to listen to it's
so obnoxious it's so egotistical
it's just utterly insane but they
started moving
the podcast and making them exclusive on
december 1st so it's only been a few
days since this has been happening
so but the other episodes were supposed
to stay is an archive forever
yes but i'm saying through this
transition there could be some kind of
rearrangement saying
we might not be getting the views we
want one of the videos on the
on spotify had 1.8 million views which
is
actually not you can see the viewership
uh this is what the
sports keita is reporting that his
latest video has 1.8 million views
so that's still pretty good was that
moxie marlon spike um i'm not sure
let's just say that old dude no no
offense dude
but white hair to solder what's the
process to sign up to spotify do you
need to pay for a membership do you need
to like
you need you so i think for uh
you might have to sign in for the roman
podcast i'm not sure yes
uh i know that it's free it's free if
you want to listen to it
but uh i'm not sure if you have to sign
in to listen to it i think you probably
do to watch too is it
is it and then you can watch it no
comments right people were like there's
no comments on spotify is that true yeah
no comments wow that's a big change
right and that's why clearly youtubers
are upset yeah one of the reasons why
you know so many people loved the joe
rogan podcast was when it was live
people were able to talk to each other
uncensored and there was just a
doubt average of like so many people
talking all at once and
and a lot of people got a lot of good
information from the comment section i
thought he disabled comments and
he did but his previous videos
had um had the comments going through it
and then after the video was done
everyone was able to comment i'm gonna
pop comment it was voted up i'm gonna be
completely honest with everybody
uh everybody knows i know joe it's cool
dude we we i i talk to him fairly often
um i think i think he got an amazing
deal i guess it was reported in the wall
street journal was like 100 million
bucks
no no like i can clearly understand why
i took it
but i think to be totally honest one of
the things that helped joe remain on top
as the biggest podcast in the world
was that he was the first in it's saying
his first and best dressed
what happens is joe works ever his show
is consistent
was it monday through thursday new
episode never misses a beat
he he puts it up on itunes when when
podcasts are first coming out he was
doing podcasts before podcasts were a
thing
so when people are first getting
introduced to podcasting they open their
iphone
they click the podcast button and
there's joe rogan the first thing they
see free advertising on the most
prominent podcasting app
that's true for youtube as well he's
been on the platform for a really long
time
the algorithm loves long-form content
and clips with high engagement
so youtube's promoting him like crazy
and he was getting algorithmic boosts
and
it was authentic it wasn't poppy it
wasn't corporate it wasn't disney
it was him talking about guerrilla dmt
monkeys ripping each other to shreds
which is fascinating to to listen to it
was fun and then he did it but one thing
i have to give him props for is he did
it in a way where
he wasn't he wasn't cocky about it he
wasn't
uh you know elitist about it it was him
discovering information
learning and taking you along the
process as he was learning it
and that's what really drove a lot of
people to listen because they wanted to
join that authentic
real honest conversation that you can't
get anywhere else because most news guys
are there with the suit and they have
their little monotone but
right right but listen listen we uh what
we do on this show
is derivative of what joe started doing
10 years ago yeah
and so i think about someone like casey
neistat you guys know you know
vlogger he was the first vlogger to
actually make
cinematic editing you know in his vlogs
before him it was like
a dude with a cell phone walking around
talking about their day they were
getting a
crazy viewership then casey comes around
and he's like i'm gonna put my camera
down
turn it on then leave the room and then
walk back in to get it to this like edit
play music time lapses and all of a
sudden his channel skyrocketed to 10
million subs in a very short amount of
time
he made hbo documentaries before doing
the vlog right so he was a professional
he yeah right it was beautiful what he
did but so here's what happens at a
certain point everybody
is making identical vlogs to him and
then it dilutes the market share
so like what i'm kind of getting at is
of course joe rogan is completely unique
superstar mma comedian he's a really
funny guy he's got his talent
but i think what was really keeping him
in the top spot was the fact that
he was given this prominent real estate
by being first and best dressed
i'm not saying that you know his show is
going to fail by any means i'm just
saying
a large portion of the viewership was is
due to algorithms and i'll admit this
for myself too because i'm not trying to
drag anybody else
i know for a fact the youtube algorithm
drives the majority of my content
the reason you are all probably
listening to this right now is because
it popped up on your front page when you
went to youtube.com
you thought this is interesting
conversation by joe rogan you clicked it
many of you probably aren't even
subscribed
you just happen to be passing by a large
portion of your ship are from
non-subscribers
and it's because the algorithm chose to
promote you subscribe by the way youtube
totally controls who sees your videos
and who doesn't and that main
front screen on youtube.com determines
everything
it used to be with the amount of views
so it used to be loose change came out
and that was the number one viewed video
it was out number one
platform now it's all algorithms
do you know deciding what's good for you
i was going to ask you what
what do you think is the current the the
best first
and best dressed now do you have any
there is no first in okay
unless we do like like first in is like
when this first started when podcasting
became a thing
joe was already there and he had a show
that was really interesting
is there anyone that is doing any
content right now that you could say is
similar we're we're well past that point
of getting the initial boost
yeah so now it's just we're all at a
party if someone wants to jump up and
down and scream and get attention they
can there was like
but i want to tell people hard numbers
take a look at the view count on this
video
okay for those that are watching live
you're going to see i think we've got
around you know 46 000 or so people
i think when all is said and done this
episode's going to have around 200
or like 300 maybe 400 000 viewers it
depends you know um
three to six viewership yeah yeah
sometimes they're bigger
but when they're like just running the
run of the you know like our average
episodes will probably hit around four
hundred thousand
you wanna know how much they get on all
podcast platforms combined
35 35 000. and
guess what one of the top global
podcasts we are
ranked i think top 230 biggest podcast
in the world but we're getting this 1000
percent more views on youtube well uh
10 10 times a thousand right right
you're right you're right
uh on my show on the tim pool daily show
i get uh between the three videos maybe
like you know two or three million views
a day or more
actually yeah it's way more than that i
was getting around i've kind of lowered
the amount of content i was doing but i
was getting
about you know four to five million
views on my youtube content every day
the podcast ranked at its peak number 34
itunes top charts in the world 70 000.
wow that that's that's how dramatically
different the numbers are
compared to youtube so i bring that up
because
i think by taking these videos off
youtube and by leaving youtube
and and it means with most respect for
you know joey's a friend uh
i think he's gonna lose a ton of
influence but i'm not i'm not entirely
convinced that something he cares about
to be honest yeah i mean he cashed out
kudos good good good job he's starting
his own comedy club i think he
wants to do exactly what he wants to do
without negotiating the network of
comedy and tech i mean listen this is so
awesome guaranteed income no banning
and so spotify is up spotify he's the
biggest number one on spotify and his
clips are still on youtube
on the jre channel so he's still putting
clips with links to his spotify content
and the clips are still getting
hundreds of thousands if not millions of
views so maybe maybe he's just
diversifying as uh
it's true but the big issue i guess is
you know at the end of the day joe's got
to do what's good for joe
he's just a guy he's doing his thing and
you can't expect anything from him
there's a lot of people who they they
looked up to him as an important figure
in the culture
because joe wouldn't just go along
blindly
with he doesn't just go along blindly
with this you know with what's going on
in left or right or whatever
he's just like a regular guy who will
challenge things they don't seem to make
sense and he'll call out people on his
own show for it
as much as the left tries to argue he
doesn't losing him
in the most prominent positions of the
culture war
scares a lot of people and i'm sure the
left is clapping and cheering the whole
time
and they're trying to use that now that
change to get him banned off spotify too
yeah we have to understand here there
was a lot of establishment
pressure a lot of pressure from the
mainstream media a lot of
you know pressure from what people would
consider the ruling class to get him
canceled to get him
kicked off of youtube so this could be
another reason why he moved over to
spotify where as you said
you can't be censored and uh i think
that's something important to really
consider here they were also going after
friends on his show of course that was
crazy nearly two billion
views removed from his channel i wonder
if all of those have translated over to
to this to spotify
you know i got i got to be honest though
uh i don't get nearly
any views on spotify or downloads for
the podcast it's it's negligible
i don't even bother with it there's
nothing i can do i mean look if you're
listening right now
hop over to spotify give us a good
review on itunes we continually are
going up in the rankings people are are
subscribing people are following people
are leaving you know good reviews and
good comments
and i can see like a month ago this show
wasn't even in the top charts
and now it's officially correct it's the
itunes top 250 is their official like
breakdown for the top podcasts
and now we're we're doing it spotify
nothing is there a link to spotify on
the youtube video
no that's that'll probably work and
there's some videos uh
he's saying go check out our full
episodes on spotify so that does happen
to me this is kind of very similar to a
move we see done
by howard stern when he moved over from
you know regular radio
facing pressure from the ftc uh and all
the other government agencies
and he just moved over to yeah but
what's he what's he's gone
yeah what's his his relevance is i know
it's like the value of money and the
value of
rel of like personal relevance to
society and
this is the great you know lesson of our
time
and joe's in the middle of it so i'm
going to be happy to hear his look on it
in the future looking
back he's got no obligation to anybody
but himself that's true you know so if
he says he's going to take
a a good deal and then look i i know a
lot of people are angry because
he is a powerful every man who when he
has conversations about social justice
warriors and like authoritarianism
he's far from conservative but he's like
that's that's bs i'm not going to play
that game
he talks about fun interesting things to
have him move away to an exclusive
platform is like
it's devastating for the culture war
it's it's a huge win for the leftists
no doubt i want to see howard stern and
rogan do something now
i don't know i i doubt howard stern
could big daddy stern got us got his
contract
oh yeah but he also became kind of
establishment yeah he totals down power
can he not say anything on the show he
denied ever saying racial slurs like on
this one a segment
and then they played it for him and he
was like i'm so sorry i did that
no no joke howard stern apologizing
for being a shock jockey so if someone
offered you 100 million would you jump
i you have obligation to i guess i i got
to be real though i
i probably wouldn't i probably would not
that's a lot of money
yeah but what am i going to do with it i
don't know
that's what i'm saying like what's the
question if you have something to do
with it then i can see going for it
create a beanie school where you teach
other beanie wearers to be
truth speakers listen listen let's start
with our own youtube channels right now
we're talking about getting a hundred
acre farm
in in central west virginia middle of
nowhere
hours from anything and like the agents
are like you really don't want to be
here there's no there's nothing and it's
like
oh yeah that's exactly what we want we
want to build that we're going to build
our own space out
you know how much you know you know how
much 100 acres can cost if you go to
like montana or something
it's like nothing couple hundred bucks a
month on a mortgage
and you can have a hundred two hundred
acres of just big open empty land
so if you wanna do something you you
could really just do it
it's not the most difficult thing i mean
obviously if you're younger it's a lot
harder you got to save up money
clearly that's you know when i was
younger i worked fast food i worked you
know crummy jobs and just saved
everything i could
the main important thing that people
need to realize is one of the most
important things you could do is
enjoy yourself whatever you're doing
whatever you're working towards if
you're enjoying yourself keep on doing
it
so i think that's essentially what i
think is going down to
to to rogan's decision he likes doing
them
he likes doing the podcasts there's a
lot less pressure on him to
to for it to be taken down and he's
going to continue his own way and as
just as you said he has no obligation to
any of us
yeah and that's that's an important
realization that a lot of people need to
make stop looking up to
idols or other individuals don't put any
man above yourself
you yourself have to look up to yourself
internally and always
build yourself up as much as you can i
will say this though you know trying to
be respectful because
again i know joe i'm not trying to drag
him or anything but when you tell
everybody don't worry the episodes are
going to be archived forever they'll
always exist you can watch them whenever
you want on youtube
and then you take them all off people
are going to be like yo
yeah that's kind of i never heard him
say that he did say that specifically
i thought that's what the deal was i was
always so vague i didn't know
plus he was like behold into ad revenue
before and now
he's not now he gets it ahead of time so
he can just kind of
so you guys can correct me if i'm wrong
but going to something like spotify like
joe did it seems kind of to me like a
soft retirement
it really seems like a semi-retirement
he's kind of done he just wants to chill
he doesn't have to worry about youtube
and all this
could be but at the same time he did
want to host a joe biden
versus a donald trump president if
you're hosting a huge presidential
debate you're not riding off into the
sunset how much
you're putting yourself in the spotlight
how much of that was him just like you
know in the moment
no i mean you saw it in his eyes he was
excited he wanted it he was like i want
donald trump here joe biden here and
alex jones talking about
the corner i want it right now and and
america would have loved that and we
deserved that
maybe maybe look maybe spotify will take
over take over itunes because of joe
that's the bet right but they also don't
have a good record when it comes to
upholding people's spotify is still
yes it's alphabet oh it is and and they
have a bad record of censoring speech
yeah yeah you know that's another aspect
that we have to
understand here it might just be
everything you know look man
eventually you're not uh 19 year old
hungry kid anymore who's trying to take
over the world you're in your 50s you
got a family and you're like how long am
i going to be leading the charge on this
one and
yeah i heard him make a comment that
like telling his family yo guys it's
time to party
we got the payout let's let's roll like
just thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast we do the
show live
monday through friday at 8 p.m so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you